joining us today welcome to the rstudio
enterprise community meetup i'm rachel
calling in from boston today i'm also
joined by tom behind the scenes helping
out with logistic logistics thank you
tom
if you've just joined now feel free to
introduce yourselves through the chat
window and say hello maybe where you're
calling in from
i do want to take a moment to say
it's nice to be able to share some space
right now with the community
what we do at our studio is only made
possible because of a big-hearted
community
we are beneficiaries of so many selfless
community members many who are affected
by the war in ukraine
so we want to also use this opportunity
to support these folks back in any way
that we can
two of our community members sep and
birla had shared a few ways we can all
help which i'll share in the chat
if you do have other information to
share please feel free to do so in the
chat as well
thank you all
for today's meetup we are joined by my
colleague cole who is one of our
solutions engineers here at our studio
cole is going to show you uh how you can
extend connect with the server api to
see more advanced usage metrics for your
content
things like who's actually using my app
and for how long if your ceo actually
used it is viewership increasing
answers that can help focus and justify
your efforts
after cole's presentation we will have
lots of time for q a as well so
wherever you're watching from right now
if that's linkedin or twitter or youtube
you can ask questions in the chat
and that will be aggregated for us here
thank you all so much for making this a
welcoming community we really want to
create spaces where everybody can
participate and we can hear from
everyone
i want to reiterate that we love to hear
from everyone no matter your level of
experience in the field
and one quick note if you would rather
ask questions anonymously you can do so
as well through slido
tom will share on the screen here a
short link for that
as well as in the chat
but with that thank you all again for
joining us i would love to turn it over
to you cole
awesome
hello everyone
so
the link to the slides will also be up
on the screen so if you all want to
follow along
yourselves
but yes what we're going to be talking
about today is on our studio connect
tracking usage data so
i'm going to give you a quick outline of
what that looks like
the technical term for this is
instrumentation data so uh we'll get
into that in a minute but this is all
predicated on the rstudio connect server
api
um and so we're gonna start with that
and then we're gonna show some examples
they're all open source as
uh should be expected um and then uh
some kind of
ways to get involved and then the time
for questions that rachel mentioned
so
to get started we're gonna focus on the
our studio connect server api
so if you're familiar with connect which
again is a professional product that our
studio
sells to companies to for their data
science teams um
it has a server api which is important
to distinguish between
that which is a part of the product and
version with the product and the apis
that you might develop in r and python
using frameworks like plumber flask that
kind of thing so the server api has
a public documentation there's also a
version hosted with your connect server
so uh because you know again this
changes over time
there are some example ways to use the
cookbook uh sorry use the api with the
cookbook and then there are some client
libraries that can be useful so the r
library is a little bit more well
developed
here is the the link to that our package
it's not on cran yet unfortunately sorry
uh
hopefully soon but the um rsconnect
python package is the analog on the
python side of the house
but really the goal for the our studio
connect server api
is that anything you can click on and do
in the ui of connect should also be able
to be done programmatically via the api
again that's the server api so this is
not something you build
um to give you a quick overview of the
types of things that the server api
might be used for um on the left hand
side we have the types of things that
are publicly documented in the api
um this is using a recent version of
connect so
i didn't really go through the specific
versions but if you're anything in the
last six months or so should have all of
these
but there's
a bunch of types of reports and things
like that that you could build off of
the server api
um specifically something that we
highlighted recently is connect widgets
which it allows you to build landing
pages and things like that for um
customizing
the way into content
um and then what we're going to be
focused on today is specifically who
looked at this report recently so that
use case is where instrumentation data
sits so it's just a part of the our
studio connect server api
if these things over here on the right
are really exciting to you um those are
either experimental apis in the connect
api package
or are um not
possible
today unfortunately an api so we're
always happy to hear
feedback requests uh feature requests
those types of things but um but these
are things that we're excited about
working on in the future so again
focusing today on who looked at the
report recently all these other cases
are just other applications of the
server api
so
if we move on then to what is this
instrumentation data so
you could call it usage data i really
wanted to use the term instrumentation
so that way if you're searching through
the docs you know the magic word um for
your search engine foo
but
really instrumentation data is course
data that we store inside of connex
database
automatically for you when people visit
your applications
so again any application visited on
connect
has this data
stored in the database
now the types of motivating questions
that might lead you into this area um
you've kind of seen who looked at this
report recently um or which apps are
most popular
those types of things but it's important
to keep in mind this is
um
more data than logs are so it's not you
know logs that you can just add stuff
into by you know printing to the
terminal um
and it's also not like a google
analytics type of you know who clicked
on this button who clicked on this tab
um that type of thing
but i'll show you an example in a minute
of what that data looks like and it does
record the user name of user or the user
guide the user identity if the um if
users are logged in if users aren't
logged in it still records the data but
obviously there's no user id associated
with it
so if you want to try to remember the
term instrumentation data uh you can
think about it we're instrumenting your
content we're not editing your content
we're not monkeying with your content or
anything like that we're just
instrumenting it and we're logging when
we serve content from
our
our api
so the way that you access this data
it's all stored in the database the way
you access it is through the server api
and and when you do that
you can see the data so here i've loaded
that data inside of our studio
and
you can see here this is for a shiny
application and shiny applications store
the
content guide so that's the unique
identifier for a piece of content a
shiny app in this case the user guide so
you can see some ena's there from
anonymous users people that weren't
logged in to connect
you can see a user guide for users that
are logged in that visited an
application and then you can see the
start and end time we also have a little
version flag here so that way we need to
change this in the future we can
for everything else on connect so
flask apps plumber apis static content
what you'll see instead is a there's a
different api request
and what you will see is
just a visit time um so it's it's
there's not a notion of a session so to
speak and so what you see is just hey
there was a visit at this time so you
don't get this start and end kind of
notion of how long were things open for
but everything else does have data so
again no matter what you're deploying to
connect you will have usage data here
and you can retrieve that
using the api
so i'm going to pivot from this this is
hopefully a bit of a
high level overview of what is this
stuff again it's course data that
you
we gather for you on your applications
if you didn't know about this feature
and you've had connect for a while
hopefully if you have a recent enough
version we've been capturing it for a
long time and so you have a bunch of
data there that you get to go analyze
i also want to note before we get into
the examples here
that the idea behind this we talked
about building our you know a bunch of
dashboards and stuff like that inside of
connect on this but we thought about
our users our data scientists
no matter what we build they probably
can build something better so uh
the the goal of the api was to make this
extensible make it something that you
can build your own reports your own
applications
to display this data analyze it however
is most useful to you but we want to
have the examples out there in the world
so that um you have a place to get
started
so the first case i'm going to look at
here is an example report
and this is a
static it's generated with our markdown
it's a static report um actually written
by sean lop if you're if any of you have
met him in the past um
and so he wrote this report
that um
it again generally with our markdown it
retrieves all the data and then stores a
static report on your server so this is
really useful if you want to do
something like run it on a schedule and
just get this report in your email
and so i have links here in the slides
to the source code for the application
as well as an example dashboard
so let's take a look um at
that real quick
so this is the report as it's deployed
on our connect server again this is
public this url you should be able to
visit in your browser it's linked there
in the slides
um and
it's it's got some nice little
client-side functionality so you get
these little tooltips and stuff but but
we're only just showing kind of the top
five of most popular shiny applications
here on the top um as well as the top
five uh most popular static content so
you see some apis here some streamlet
stuff
and uh this is a static site so this is
just javascript um and html that's out
there and then the most popular users
and uh you know for each different
content types
but what's cool about this is unconnect
right we have the feature to ship emails
whenever a report runs and so we also
um this is i just generated this email
preview so that you can see what it
might look like in your email inbox
and so this is an email that could get
sent out to the data science team and
say hey look these are the most popular
applications for the last 30 days
so if something like this seems useful
for you again good news
this is out there on the internet all of
the source code is here all you have to
do is add your uh environment variables
which new versions of connect
automatically do this for you so you
literally can just type in this url and
uh there's a manifest here so you can
use get back deployment and deploy it to
connect server if you want and uh i hope
it works if it doesn't please open an
issue because we would love to make sure
that it works for you
so
we have got the our markdown
example
and i feel like i'm going really fast
but
such is life um
yeah i think in youtube you can slow
things down if you if i'm talking too
fast
um so yeah so let's go from the report
to the application so an application as
you might expect is a little bit more
interactive
and so i wrote this last night so i may
have bugs
but i felt like we needed an application
to go with this there are some really
good ones in the community but uh but i
wanted just a simple example to um for
y'all to to take a look at and the idea
here is that you could interactively
explore the data a little bit it's it's
less static it's not going to show up in
your email inbox but it gives you a
little bit more you know
opportunity to
float through the data yourself however
data volume matters a lot more and it
just so happens that our connect server
that we use for demos is really busy it
gets lots of traffic and as a result um
i had to do be a little crafty about how
i implemented it
but
it is public this url is also available
if you want to go poke around and it's
kind of fun you
edit the
you know you can edit the timeline and
look at what applications
uh what who is viewing it and then you
know which owner uh is most popular if
you will which um i promise i didn't
plan things this way i just happen to
own an app that's kind of popular but
it's also kind of fun seeing my name is
like the mvp
but uh but yeah so you can monkey around
with this again all of the source code
is uh on the internet
and
we um
you should be able to
deploy this to your server and poke
around again only the top 20 because we
have tons of apps on this server and we
wanted to just highlight that
if you all want to go to this url that
again should should work for you
and
down here you can see i'm using a
package called apex charter
which you can interact as you interact
with this you can see the data
modified there on the side which is
actually kind of funny because you can
see there's a little bug there it says
edgar but i clicked on andre
that's awesome so um so anyways
always good finding bugs in open source
packages
but again links are in the slides
and
you're welcome to take a look at
the
app itself as it's hosted our little
screenshot here
or again take the source code take the
manifest just deploy it to your connect
server whatever is most useful for you
so in this repo so this is one of the
things i'll talk more about in a second
but
this repository is where we've tried to
centralize a little bit the examples for
usage data inside of our studio connect
or instrumentation data again if you
want to use the formal term
and there are a couple of other examples
here so connect vis is a package that a
community member has been maintaining
and building and so
this is just a kind of teaser for them
and an example there
there's also a connect analytics package
which uh similarly is maintained by a
member of the community and i'm sure
there are many more awesome examples out
there we've talked to a bunch of
customers that have built their own
dashboards
sometimes they can't share those though
because of you know ndas and all that
jazz but but we still love seeing this
kind of stuff and we love whenever it's
useful for y'all
so hopefully
this will be
so we've gone through the examples and
now uh what's next
so i want to recap all this data is
automatically stored by connect so
connect has it as a publisher or an
administrator to a connect server you
have access to this data something i
didn't mention is that if you're a
publisher you don't get like see the
entire world privileges like i have as
an administrator
but you can see all of the usage data
for your applications um and that uh you
know so these reports still should be
excuse me useful
for you and so you can still deploy
these applications that kind of thing um
you just need to use the api key of an
administrator if you want kind of global
see all of the reports that kind of
thing
so we started a discussion on our studio
community
so if you want to
be a part of a discussion that lives a
little bit longer than this live stream
then this is a good place to do that
then there are the open source examples
which we love contributions issues
comments those types of things
you could also build your own open
source packages or tooling to make this
kind of display easier
and then
whether or not you are able to in your
workplace
share this data publicly or these
reports in the code publicly
we would still love to hear it so
feel free to contact your csrap
weekend customer success representative
and and we would love to hear uh what's
going on whether whether there are new
features you need um whether things have
worked well um our studio connect team
loves to have that feedback as well and
then
feature requests again are always
welcome
as well
so
hopefully this uh has been an
interesting kind of
teaser to get the
um
usage data
in your brain and
starting to like think about what are
some cool things that you could build
the um
here are some sample questions that
maybe if you want to respond to in the
chat
would be most welcome i i have to admit
i'm
both surprised and appreciative i wanted
to show this this is a bit of a last
minute thing
i built a real-time usage data dashboard
too
and this one is watching our demo server
to just in case like everybody at once
just all tried to like jump on our demo
server and it started to you know suffer
um
but nobody did so that's good we had a
workshop this morning so you can see
this big spike here um you can see my
testing here and here um and then this
is the workshop probably wrapping up and
this is y'all not bum rushing my server
so thank you
but um at the same time if you do visit
the application url so the shiny app url
um
then uh then this
number should start increasing so
uh maybe that's i don't know a teaser
introduction to breaking my server and
making me work hard so
good times but i would love to open for
questions so
i don't know if there are any in the
chat but we can
start on that yeah i can help um pull
questions up for you cole and tom if you
could put the link to the slido on the
screen that would be helpful too so you
can ask questions either in youtube live
if you're there if you're on linkedin
you can put them in the comments
or you can ask questions anonymously
through that slido link on the screen
but cool one of the questions that came
earlier was
is this feature included in all our
studio connect licenses or is it a
premium thing that not everybody would
have
yeah that's a great question so this is
included in all studio connect licenses
um so any our studio connect will have
this the one caveat is that um api
hosting is a
uh base feature i think
maybe standard feature standard i forget
all the names standard yep thank you
um the uh and so
obviously we don't have instrumentation
data for content that can't be deployed
to connect so um if you want to publish
a plumber api or flask api or something
like that um that is a
feature that requires the standard kind
of license
so that's the only
limitation that um that i think should
be there so if you have a connect server
you should have this data available to
you
it's a great question
cole can i ask you a question as someone
who manages our own internal server or
yeah i mean you doing that but
um is there something that you would
wish that this dashboard had or
something that you're hoping the
community might be able to help
contribute to
yeah
yeah so um something this is partly like
one of the things that i um
this is kind of a fun backstory so i
used to be a teblo administrator and um
and i had tableau has a similar type of
like instrumentation data usage data
that kind of thing um and i had this
little chart that i really liked that i
built with a packed um bubble plot and
so then you could like click on the
bubbles and it would filter the other
bubbles and like it was just kind of fun
um i don't know how useful it was you
know i mean there might be some database
experts who are like yeah i don't use uh
packed bubble charts anyways packed
mobile charts are uh i don't know i
couldn't find a good library for them
inside of the r ecosystem so i my goal
with this little demo application
was to be able to click on the little
bars and filter things and i ran out of
time so i didn't do that so um i think
really like interactive dashboards that
allow you to kind of dive through the
data is um is where the connect vis
package is going is where
there are a lot of opportunities for
this type of thing and so i would really
love to see
those types of
apps out there more of like more of like
the interactive kind of dive through the
data because it does it takes time to
build those types of things
but we we love to celebrate them on the
connect usage repo and and we would love
to contribute and um
sometimes just time gets in the way of
like
building applications i've had this idea
actually this real time dashboard um
delio
this has been an idea in my head for
like uh
two years
or more
yeah three and a half three years and
some change um
and i finally coded it up this morning
so
anyways i would love to see more stuff
like this because i feel like my
imagination is not
quite as robust as a lot of the people
in our community so i'm just mostly
excited to see what they dream up i'm
glad we gave you the inspiration to make
that this morning
i see there's quite a few anonymous
questions coming in too and one was
when will the connect api be released to
cran or do you have an anticipated date
yes uh such a good question um
well
unfortunately
i don't know because i was hoping to do
it like by the end of last year so
i am delayed um but
that said um we are kind of leaning for
soonish
um so anyways if you are using the
connect api package and um
uh i would love if you could update to
the most recent version and just make
sure there are no bugs
having some issues come in would be a
good sanity check that like okay
we need to fix these bugs before we put
on cran um but yes we are planning to
put it on crayon um in the in the
nearest future
but uh but there's just a lot of other
priorities that kind of get in the way
sometimes so we're also trying to
restructure that so it's not i'm not the
bottleneck on on that either so
apologies for the delay this is
something we've been wanting to do for a
long time and uh hopefully it'll be as
soon as she
as soon as she i like it
can you um reiterate how people could
access it today if it's not on crayon
yes that's a fantastic question so
inside of
your r studio session
which one moment please
here we go
i'm going to move my little dashboard
away
so if you're inside of our studio
this is me inside of our studio um
and uh what you want to do is you want
to use the rose package or dev tools and
uh install github
and then our studio slash connect api
and that should get you the latest
version unless you have a bad github pat
in your environment
um unset f github
then it won't work
and you'll look silly on your demo
and
in my case i have the latest version so
it's not going to ask me to um install
it unless i say force true and then it's
going to ask me to install the entire
world
but i'm going to say no thank you
um
and then i'm going to have another
problem good times so this is why live
coding demos can be uh problematic but
anyways this code should generally work
most of the time
and if it doesn't
um
you have to figure out what is going on
here and i think this is my with our
packages needs to be updated so i
probably should have said yes
maybe but with ours not being updated
here anyways
remotes install github our studio slash
connect api and then
tsunashi we will have installed that
packages connect api and the world would
be a much happier place and i won't have
this issue
awesome thanks cole
there was a question that was will this
be available late um will this recording
be available later and yes on the our
studio youtube
the link that you're on right now if
you're watching it on youtube we'll just
turn into the recording there
another question was
uh let's see could you speak to the
development alignment of
the connect api verse rs connect api
releases which is recommended to
incorporate
interesting
i'm not sure i'm completely following
that question um
i'll try to speak to it i think the rs
connect api releases is that talking
about our studio connect server api
releases
that sounds yeah that makes sense okay
cool i'm uh
tracking here i think so inside of um
and i'll clarify the question a little
bit in case somebody's confused so
inside of um
our documentation
right we have this api reference and
this is always this url that's public is
always for the most recent version of
connect so you can see this is a release
that we did um
very really recently like i think this
was last week maybe um so i haven't even
updated our demo server yet because i've
been focusing on preparing for this
webinar
um but if i go to my connect server and
i go to the documentation tab you can
see i'm running a different version of
connect
and so i'm not using the same version of
the api
that
like
that is public on the internet so if i
click on this this server documentation
again this is in my connect
you know installation if you will
you can see it has a different version
of the api
and so
what what the question is asking about
is
i have a version of connect installed
and there's a latest version of connect
installed that's on the internet um
like that has the documentation hosted
on the internet so here um and if you're
wondering why this dark theme is there
it's just a browser add-in so um it's
the same it's the same exact
documentation um
but
and the question is okay well how does
connect api track against this so the
good thing is we try to change this
connect server api relatively
infrequently
and so
there's not a whole lot of um changes
that
happen now occasionally changes do
happen and so what we try to do within
the next api package is to track the
latest and so if you go to our studio
connect api
pass the bison i hope those are bison i
don't know what they are
horned creatures
um so if you look at the connect api
package
there is a magic uh variable
somewhere
that has
the version and there's a function that
like shows what version it'll warn you
if the version's different but this is
the version that we have tested with
connect api and we have our little
integration test suite and everything's
happy go lucky
so
we will bump this soon to the newest
version of connect and make sure that
everything works and all that jazz if
the version of connect that you're using
is different from this version
then we'll throw a little warning like
hey just so you know
the version that you are using
of connect is different from the version
that we tested the package with that
warning is mostly an fyi and most of the
time it's not going to have issues um
and so that's a good thing normally
things are pretty backwards compatible
we try to be really careful about
breaking backwards compatibility both on
the connect side as well as on the
connect api side
but there are occasionally breakages so
um for instance one of those is the acl
like how you look at which users have
accessed applications um we did throw in
a warning of like hey this version of
connect api 0.1.0.1927
these versions will get nicer whenever
we go to cran
um
we change things right so
this this api is deprecated you should
not be using this function instead you
should be using this git content
permissions function
so we try to be really careful about
backwards compatibility hopefully it's
all just always happy go lucky if you
run into issues again issues are welcome
and
and we try to also warn you if we know
that we broke something we try to update
things there we also try to throw things
in this giant news file
so you'll see some breaking changes here
um
we changed like for instance the
signature on some of these vanity url
changes um when the apis went public
so anyways there are a couple of places
to check and then we try to warn you if
you're running into something that is a
breaking change for sure
and
the last thing is if you're using
experimental api we also warn you and
say hey this is experimental just so you
know it might change
so um
the way that i recommend to generally
use
this package um is to
if you have content that depends on it
um whenever like try to coordinate
development on that with the upgrade of
connect and kind of
you might want to upgrade connect and
then upgrade the connect api package and
that should generally keep you happy we
talk about that here
as well kind of how to manage this kind
of stuff and feedback again is always
super welcome
so that was a lot to say but hopefully
that was a useful answer to your
question we do our best and it's kind of
hard to do sometimes
thanks cole
there's quite a few questions coming in
on slido right now and um
most upvoted one so far is is there a
technical difference with the
instrumentation data that is available
with the built-in uh sqlite config of
rstudio connect versus the postgres
config
yeah that's
such a good question man that's awesome
so um so yes so the instrumentation data
is the same
however there is a caveat and the caveat
is an unfortunate one that i'm hopeful
we get a chance to remedy at some point
soon ish
you can see how i think about things i
just want everything to be soonish um
the
the instrumentation data is in a
separate
uh area if you will inside of the
database and so
when you switch from sqlite to postgres
we don't yet have a way to migrate all
of that data from sqlite to postgres so
the the data is the same on both ends
but sqlite and postgres and all of other
databases out there in the world have
their own way of notating things like
dates and booleans and all that kind of
jazz and so as a result the migration
story is not a very good one today but
that's something that we again would
love to improve and if you are in this
case where you're like man we're
thinking about switching to postcards
and we don't want to lose all our data
definitely reach out to us we would love
to kind of chat with you through that um
through that experience
and so that's the one caveat this is a
really good question because
there shouldn't be and uh and we want
there not to be a difference at all
between the two and to be able to have a
smooth migration story but today the
migration story is the weak spot in that
kind of
setup
so um so yes no difference
unless you're trying to switch across in
which case the history won't be
maintained so you want to be you want to
be thoughtful about that
um if you can be and reach out to us
again if you're having trouble because
that's always helpful
thanks coal
another question was could you clarify
between connect widgets and today's
examples with the instrumentation data
yes
man these questions are so good so if we
go to github
and go to connect widgets
so the connect widgets package
is really oriented around
um a custom kind of
dashboard if you will like landing page
for our studio connect content
so
what what that would look like is inside
of um
where do i want to go i want to go
let's go back up here
so remember there were a couple
different things and we're really
focused on this who looked at this
report recently
connect widgets is really focused on
this landing page so for instance if i
had a bunch of applications let's say i
have a bunch of applications that are
focused on usage i might want a landing
page that's just for applications that
are
oriented around usage so i might tag
them all and say all of these
applications have a usage tag on it and
then i might build a report
using connect widgets to say these are
all the reports that
that
are
show you your usage data so that
somebody could go to
you know connect.com slash usage
whatever my connect url is slash usage
and then i would get a landing page and
it would have like quick links to all of
the other usage dashboards so that i
could kind of go to the one that i want
and flip between them easily and that
kind of thing so connect widgets is
really about the landing page and so
what that would look like is onsite on
our studio connect
in a where am i in here
so con connect widgets is really focused
on pages
like um we have a lot of content on the
server so
patience is good um
this
this page right so connect widgets is
really about changing the experience of
finding content
and uh you know giving you some
customization for this kind of meta like
inside of connect building landing pages
for connect
the the usage dashboard is all about who
is using the other applications on
connect and how much and so what's kind
of interesting is that though they hold
different kind of homes and use cases
you could time together right like for
instance you could tie together and have
a report that displays all the content
that is most popular
um so you could you could do all kinds
of things um they're they're scoped in
different kind of spaces um the connect
widgets package uses the connect api as
well it doesn't use the connect api
package yet because connect api is not
on cran um but eventually these things
will all be hopefully tied together
nicely and uh yeah so if you're if
you're wanting to display content use
connect widgets if you're wanting to
look at usage data use um
instrumentation data and if you want
those things together you can do that so
good times
thanks cole
i see sam had asked a question earlier
on slido that was is there a similar
capacity available for shiny server open
source to track many apps on the server
that is a great question
i don't believe so i think um i have to
admit i'm very rusty on chinese server
um
so
so yeah i don't believe so although i
know that there have been
kind of diy approaches to using things
like uh matomo is like an open source
google analytics there's there's some
other alternatives as well um
yeah tom has got a really cool link here
that i want to share
on
usage metrics
does this talk about shiny server pro
yeah cool let me find where's
brave
so this is a um
anyways there are ways to do this um
they are a bit uh old
but but they should still work and so
this is an example i believe using
google analytics um or matomo in this
case uh for
tracking and this would be the more
granular data around your application
right so you could do things like who
clicked on which button
that kind of stuff so there definitely
are options
to do it um it is a little bit more diy
unfortunately um connect and chinese
server are a very different beast so
like the mechanism is is very different
but but you totally can accomplish those
types of things using open source
tooling and building that type of
capability for sure
and even more granular again if you eat
whether you're using connect or shiny
server pro or shiny server rather um
you can um
you can use
these more granular analytics to get
data around who's using which buttons
kind of like a standard website
and so that should all be possible
and uh yeah
thanks cool that was actually one of the
other questions on slido
like if you could see exactly who was
viewing the app and how would you be
able to do that in the dashboard
right so um and that's thinking about
like more of like a real-time sense i
imagine
i think to know like exactly who from
your company
was seen was viewing it and won
yeah so that is definitely doable
and so
is this the app yeah yeah so and you can
see that here
right so these are the owners of the
applications so the people that have
built applications on the server
but these are the viewers of the
application and so
i didn't i didn't hook up the click the
other direction right that if i click on
this it goes back and filters the
timeline but the data is very granular
and so if you remember back to um in our
presentation when we show the example
data this user good here is the user
within your application so there's
another um
endpoint that allows you to retrieve the
users and do a join um and get the user
data and so the username can be i mean
their email address i mean whatever
right um can be correlated with the
application and you can see the time
right so you can see who visited when
and i have aggregated that in this
example but inside of the code you can
see all of these examples so um if you
look at where i'm getting the viewer
from
so there's the viewer
so i'm taking the raw shiny data um i'm
filtering if there is a
time stamp selected a time window
selected then i'm grouping by the user
id tallying and then i'm joining
the
user data
based on the guide and the username and
then arranging descending um by the the
count and so
hopefully these examples can kind of uh
sharpen your appetite a little bit and
uh and get you thinking about this
because you do have that granular data
and i just kind of didn't show a very
user specific uh
view i guess within the application that
i uh that i built as an example yep
thanks cool yeah i think i messed up
reading that question out because
they're also asking or saying a report
on what user is using which app like
shiny or our markdown would be useful to
maybe more like
user focus reports too
yeah
yeah exactly and so you could totally
think about like it's a small
modification to this application
that when i click on david let's say
it filters the timeline so i can see
when is david most active it filter it
could filter the owner like which
reports does david like to view right
like who is who is david's app builder
if you will um and it could filter this
by app to see what are the apps that
david's viewing so you could totally
build these uh you know types of
these types of interaction for sure and
again this example app is just using
shiny data
but again inside of the source code you
can see this nice little commented
outline here
that is how you would retrieve the
static usage data i was originally doing
that you can see it took about three
minutes to run that request i have a
cache so it's good but um i wasn't
displaying the data and so i i didn't um
you know put it in here but
again uncommenting this and then
creating a view for it or
aggregating it in and you would have the
markdown reports and
api requests and all those things in
there as well so
yes all of that granularity of who's
looking at which app when
and um if you're on a shiny app how long
right all of those questions can totally
be answered and
the limitation right now is just
the quality of our examples but again
connectviz has some other examples that
are that are good connect analytics has
some so there's there's some other
examples in the open source community
you can use
i see lauren commenting am i the top
three in the viewer list i love connect
yep
yep really is top two if uh if we
discount all the people who use our
server that aren't users right they're
just kind of public visitors
so yeah
it's fun i know this question was
showing previously thank you tom
for cole the question was is it possible
to know which shiny tab or plot or table
is mostly viewed and clicked
that would be a nice feature also a good
feature would be to predict the next
visits
yes
see these are the types of things that i
feel like yeah there should be like a
hackathon for like
viewer trendline prediction um yes so
these are great yeah we love feature
requests um the the reason that we don't
have more granular data is uh because
when
when our studio connect is serving your
application we get the request for the
application or for the api or those
types of things
the more granular data happens inside of
your application right inside of the
front end um of the application so
that's sitting different from us and to
in order to get more granular data we
would have to like start monkeying with
the r process which is kind of gross we
don't want to do that um and so
really that's where i think there are
open source kind of initiatives there on
the more granular data i think there's
like a shiny analytics package um there
are the google analytics or matomo
analytics that i mentioned um that are
pure front-end kind of analytics so um
it's not something that we have a plan
to build currently for like again the
more
inside of an application what's going on
what's most popular but there are um
kind of patterns there and and so it's
just kind of more on the open source
ecosystem today but yeah if we can find
a way to do that that would be i agree
that would be very cool to just kind of
get it for free
definitely
another question was how stable is the
connect api our package it seems like a
lot of functions were changed recently
yeah so that's a great great question so
stability is always
in the eye of the beholder i would say
um
and so if you look at the questions that
have changed recently right one of the
things about our news file is because
we've never released a crayon like
everything just gets piled up so when
you look at recent
this is like over the past
like
couple years um
and generally speaking
i feel like i haven't really done much
on this package over the last couple
years so from my point of view it feels
like it hasn't changed that much what
has changed and why there are some of
these breaking notes it's also worth
noting these breaking notes are kind of
like
uh
a very very particular person's breaking
notes right like for instance we renamed
the argument to a function so
technically it would break but literally
all you have to do is change server to
host
or something like that host a server and
and that'll resolve the issue so we try
to make these breaking notes so it's
like hey these are the things to look at
but
once an api is stable and documented and
public
that's where things definitely slow down
and are more stable and
you can see in our documentation that
most of the functions that used to be
experimental inside of connect api are
now stable and so
as we move all of them to being publicly
documented stable apis um the stability
of connect api will continue to improve
but but yes it generally speaking
i have
had to do very little in the way of
changing these reports once i like
switched them over to connect api a
couple years ago and then left it um
connect api was not the reason that they
broke um if that is helpful at all but
again we would definitely be open to
resolving issues and things like that if
if you all find them
but the goal is to be as stable as
possible
um and that's sometimes hard to balance
with like
having the new feature for the new
people that are trying to have the new
features
definitely
i see there was a another question
earlier that was around
oh i think it maybe it was withdrawn
it was
does the r package connect api have to
be updated at the same time as the
rstudio connect server
so
generally speaking no and the reason is
because of that backwards compatibility
right connect is reluctant to break apis
and make changes um and connect api is
reluctant to break apis and make changes
and so
hopefully like there's there's there's
supposed to be a window is kind of the
goal um
that's the time to pay most attention
right if your connect version has not
changed and your connect api version has
not changed then there's really nothing
to worry about the time to pay attention
is when the connect version is changing
or when the connect api version is
changing so that's that's really the
time to be careful and to pay attention
but generally speaking
it should work
most of the time um
and by most of the time i mean like
there are edge cases right and those are
not super likely but
again we try to note them here if and
when they do appear
but um but yeah this is also one of the
pressures that has been keeping us off
of crayon a little bit is trying to
trying to get things as stable as
possible until before we put things um
out there on crayon forever
thanks cole
thank you so much for your presentation
too and sharing this with us i am i
don't see other questions but i want to
make sure that i haven't missed anything
across
linkedin twitter or youtube
i think we're all set on slido
let me double check the chat
and as i mentioned we're happy to use
this time to answer other questions
about connect2 while we're here
but cool i think it would be helpful to
if we could go back to the slide where
you kind of talked about next steps and
where people can go to
continue the conversation too
yes
yes so um so yeah so this link here is
uh just
the community uh thread that rachel
started um so again this is
maybe a harder url to remember
but inside of community if you're inside
of community an easy way to find um the
place where a lot of connect questions
are asked if you're curious you want to
see what other people are talking about
is if you go to our admins
so
perhaps a uh not as great named
name for a category now that we have
python admins right
um but if you go to r admins and then
our studio connect
this section is uh where a lot of these
types of questions are most welcome
you'll see my face a lot uh
unfortunately but this thread that
rachel started is right here
and so there's uh community.org.com and
then the links are in the discussion
thread here
but that um
that's a really good place to kind of
keep the discussion going afterwards
and then again there's the open source
kind of way of interacting and avenue on
the professional side of talking to your
customer success representative um and
uh and yeah we love to we love to keep
these conversations going we don't i've
done a lot of monologuing today
we prefer not monologuing so that's
that's definitely the the good places to
kind of stay involved and get plugged in
if you're interested on this kind of
stuff ask questions it doesn't have to
be specially formulated uh in our studio
community like it might have to be on
like stack overflow or something like
that just
i'm curious what what else does people
have people done you know what other
features are out there that people are
asking for you know unstructured
conversations are welcome
for sure and i'd love to hear from you
all if you've taken this example and
turned it into something at your own
organization too it'd be great to see
some examples of that
yeah and actually real quick i want to
show you something
we're going to pretend that i just
watched this webinar and i'm like oh
this is so cool i want to deploy this on
my connect server so you go to your
connect server hopefully it loads faster
than mine um
but again we have lots of content um
lots of uh
geyser apps actually
um but if you go to this publish button
and if your administrator has set up a
git deployment so all you have to do for
that is install git on the server at the
system level and you say import from get
and then you remember our magic url that
we
github.com
solange connect
usage this url is in the slides right
you click next
it will say what branches exist on this
repository you will click main because
you don't necessarily want to go to
close more tweaks you don't know what
that might entail
so you go to the main branch
go to next it'll find the deployable
directories
and
these will include both of the examples
today right so there's connectviz which
uses that connectviz package that's in
uh in the works in the community the
interactive app that i showed you and
the last 30 days report which is in our
markdown report so you give it a fun
name right my fun name
and then you click deploy content
and now
you have this application on your server
running with your data instead of mine
and um hopefully it'll be useful for you
so again
a couple clicks some typing and you can
have this on your server um
or again clone it into github or into
our studio monkey with it deploy it
whatever makes the most sense for you um
so i've got some packages to install it
looks like good times
but um but yeah so i wanted to show you
all that because i mentioned it earlier
but it really is pretty easy to get
access to these examples when there is a
manifest.json file in the directory
which we did so that way you could do it
so hopefully that's awesome
thank you so much cole
and as we mentioned earlier this
talk will be shared to our studio
youtube the same link you're at right
now if you're watching it live there
and we'll share all those
helpful links that are mentioned here as
well as the slides there
but again we would really love to hear
from all of you
if there's something that you've built
using this api i would love to be able
to highlight that as well
but thank you so much cole for an
awesome presentation i did one last
check for questions and i don't see any
others thank you all for joining us
today too
have a great rest of the day